LANGUAGE HERE. ALL RIGHT HERE
IN IS CALLED TO ORDER WE DON'T
YET HAVE A QUORUM WILL START AS
A SUBCOMMITTEE AND I THINK
WE'LL HAVE A QUORUM VERY
SHORTLY. A GOOD MORNING AND
WELCOME TO ASSEMBLY
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE HEARING.
HIS MASK REQUIREMENT FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS IN THE HEARING ROOM
PLEASE MAINTAIN PROPER BASQUE
USAGE AT ALL TIMES DO NOT
REMOVE OR LOWER YOUR MASK WHEN
SPEAKING WE APPRECIATE YOUR
COOPERATION IN EXPERIENCE JUST.
DESTROY PROPERTY AND INCIDENCE.
AND LEGISLATIVE HEARINGS AND
ANY CONTACT THAT DISRUPTS
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEACHED
YOU ORDERLY CONDUCT THE HEARING
IS PROHIBITED THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. A FEW DIFFERENT
OPTIONS OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY. YOU SHOULD BE
ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM WE ALSO HAVE THE
OPTION OF TESTIFYING IN OUR
REMOTE. TESTIMONY STATION
LOCATED ON THE NORTH STEPS OF
THE CAPITOL- WE ALSO WILL BE
USING MODERATE MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY IN THE
BILL. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO AGAIN THE NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
ACCESS CODE ONE THREE ONE. FIVE
FOUR TWO ZERO TWO YOU CAN ALSO
FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY
AND TOXIC MATERIALS COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO IS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL. YOUR
TESTIFIED ON IS BEGINNING THEIR
BILL PRESENTATION. ALL PHONE
TESTIMONY WILL BE TAKEN
TOGETHER AFTER BOTH SIDES
PRIMARY WITNESSES HAVE
PRESENTED. IF YOU ARE KOHLI IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVE STREAM BROADCAST AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTRICT DISTORTION.
PLEASE ALSO BE ADVISED IF YOU
pTESTIMONY FOR AGAINST BILL
REMAIN ON LIVE LINE AND WILL
NEED TO MEET YOURSELF UNTIL YOU
ARE CALLED ON TO SPEAK. IF
YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH
THE MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU
CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-3965 AND MY STAFF WILL
BE THERE TO TRY AND HELP YOU. I
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE THANK YOU FOR BEARING
WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS
TO CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA. THE FOLLOWING
BILLS WERE PULLED BY THE AUTHOR
SB FORTY TWO WHITE CAL SKI WAS
TAKEN CARE OF IN THE BUDGET
TRAILER BILL. S. B. TWO OH
SEVEN DOLLY WAS TAKEN OFF- TO-
BE AMENDED TO TREAT A LOCAL
ISSUE- THAT LEAVES US WITH TWO
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
TESTIMONY IS LISTED IS LIMITED
TO FOUR MINUTES TOTAL FOR EACH
SIDE PER BL AFTER THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT PROVIDER
TESTIMONY. WELL FIRST ASK FOR
SUPPORT WITNESSES IN THE ROOM.
I WILL DO THE SAME FOR THE
OPPOSITION. AGAIN PLEASE NOTE
THAT PHONE TESTIMONY WILL BE
COMBINED FOR BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. IT WILL BE TAKEN
AFTER BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION PRIMARY WITNESSES
HAVE TESTIFIED IN WILL BE
LIMITED TO TWENTY MINUTES OF
PHONE TESTIMONY PER B. L.
MEDICINAL WITNESSES WILL BE
LIMITED TO PLEASE STATE THEIR
NAME ORGANIZATION IF THEY
REPRESENT ONE. AND THEIR
POSITION ON THE BILL. THANK YOU.
AND LET'S SEE WE HAVE ONE TWO
THREE FOUR WE NEED ONE MORE. TO
GET A ONE MORE HERE. YEAH WE
NOW HAVE ENOUGH FOR A QUORUM
THANK YOU- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
TO ESTABLISH QUORUM. CORK HERE
WORK HERE SMITH SMITH HERE
ARAMBULA I DON'T WILL I HEAR
OUR QUE HAN. DALLY CRISTINA
GARCIA HOLDEN HOLDEN HERE
MATHIS WHAT A TO G. WHAT A TO
G. HERE WE HAVE A QUORUM OKAY
THANK YOU- I'M SORRY WE YOU
WERE PROBABLY HERE TWENTY
MINUTES EARLIER ASSET SENATOR
I'M SORRY WE DIDN'T LET YOU
KNOW THAT WE WERE STARTING A
LITTLE LATE BECAUSE PEOPLE AND
OTHER COMMITTEES THEY HAD TO BE
AT THAT'S OKAY NO PROBLEM ALL
RIGHT SO- WE HAVE S. B. SEVEN
SEVEN SIX WHICH IS BROUGHT
FORWARD BY SENATOR GONZALEZ.
THIS BILL IS A FOLLOW UP TO SB
TWO HUNDRED WHICH IS TABLETS TO
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER FUND IN TWENTY NINETEEN
PLEASE PROCEED SENATOR THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU-
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS I'M HERE
TODAY TO PRESENT SB SEVEN SEVEN
SIX AND I WANT TO FIRST THANK
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF AND FOUR
THE ANALYSIS AS WELL WHICH IS
VERY FAVORABLE THANK YOU-THIS
IS THE STATE WATER BOARDS
ABILITY TO MORE EFFECTIVELY
EFFICIENTLY IMPLEMENT SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER ACT
OF THE STATE WATER BOARD HAS
WORKED. HARD TO IMPLEMENT THE
LEGISLATURE'S VISION FOR THE
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER PROGRAM BUT AS IDENTIFIED
A NUMBER OF CLARIFYING
STATUTORY CHANGES THAT ARE
NEEDED TO QUICKLY EFFICIENTLY
PROVIDE FUNDING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES WITHOUT ANY
UNNECESSARY ADMINISTRATIVE
DELAY THESE EFFICIENCIES
INCLUDE CLARIFYING DEFINITIONS
AUTHORIZING THE BOARD TO MAKE
ADVANCE PAYMENTS PROVIDING THE
AUTHORITY TO ACT EXPEDITIOUSLY
TO PROVIDE- TO PURCHASE SOME
SORRY EMERGENCY BOTTLED WATER
AND PROVIDING THE ABILITY TO
QUICKLY SEND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS INTO A
FAILING SYSTEM. IT'S A
THOUGHTFUL MEASURE AND
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT TODAY I
HAVE JOKER KASKI THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE DIVISION OF
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE AT THE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NAY VOTE. DID AS FAST I
COULD. OUR THAT'S ACTUALLY- SO-
WE HAVE ONE PRIMARY WITNESS AND
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE LINE. YEP
HELLO THANK YOU DR COURT MY
NAME IS JEFF TARKOVSKY AND I AM
THAT DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
DIVISION OF FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE AT THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD. AS THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD WORKS TO IMPLEMENT THE
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER PROGRAM. THE BOARD HAS
IDENTIFIED SEVERAL STATUTORY
CHANGES THAT ARE NEEDED TO HELP
COMMUNITIES MORE QUICKLY. SB
SEVEN SEVEN SIX TO AUTHORIZE
THE WATER BOARD TO ISSUE A
SINGLE ORDER TO REQUIRE
MULTIPLE PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS
TO CONDUCT MONITORING OR
PROVIDE INFORMATION TO THE
BOARD. THIS IS AN EFFICIENCY
MEASURE TO SAVE RESOURCES AND
WILL HELP SUPPORT MONITOR AND
ENSURE STATE WATER QUALITY AND
PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS THAT
REQUIRE ASSISTANCE. THIS IS
CONSISTENT WITH ACTIONS TAKEN
BY THE LEGISLATURE IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
FIVE SIX. WHICH GAVE THE BOARD
AUTHORITY TO REQUIRE ALL OR ANY
GROUP OF WATER SYSTEMS TO
MONITOR FOR P. TAX. THIS BILL
WILL ALSO ALIGN THE WATER
BOARD'S DRINKING WATER
AUTHORITIES WITH ITS WATER
QUALITY AUTHORITY. SB SEVEN
SEVEN SIX ALLOWS THE WATER
BOARD TO ADOPT EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS THAT WILL HELP THE
BOARD TAKE QUICK ACTION IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT DATA IS
READILY AVAILABLE AND IT'S A
KEEPING WITH OUR EXISTING
AUTHORITIES. SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX
WILL IT STAND THE WATER PORTS
AUTHORITY TO REQUIRE TECHNICAL
REPORTS FROM STATE SMALL WATER
SYSTEMS. THIS WILL ENSURE SAFE
DRINKING WATER IN SMALL SYSTEMS
AND COMMUNITIES. AND IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE BOARD'S
CURRENT AUTHORITY TO REQUIRE
THIS INFORMATION FROM A LARGER
PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS. SB SEVEN
SEVEN SIX WILL ALSO ALLOW THE
WATER BOARD TO ADDRESS
EMERGENCY SITUATIONS THAT OCCUR
AT A FAILING WATER SYSTEM.
SPECIFICALLY THE BOARD WOULD BE
AUTHORIZED TO PROVIDE UP TO TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS WITHOUT A
WRITTEN AGREEMENT IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS A DRINKING WATER
EMERGENCY. FOR EXAMPLE TO
PROVIDE BOTTLED WATER. THE BILL
WILL ALSO AUTHORIZE THE BOARD
TO MAKE ADVANCE PAYMENTS TO
ENTITIES THAT ARE AUTHORIZED TO
RECEIVE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER FUNDS. THE WATER
BOARD GENERALLY MAKES PAYMENTS
ON A REIMBURSEMENT BASIS
HOWEVER THIS PROCESS CAN BE A
FINANCIAL BURDEN PARTICULARLY
ON DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
THAT DO NOT HAVE THE CASH FLOW
UP FRONT. THIS WILL HELP SMALL
COMMUNITIES ACCESS SAFE WATER
MORE QUICKLY. SB SEVEN SEVEN
SIX INCLUDES AN EXEMPTION FROM
CERTAIN STATE CONTRACTING
REQUIREMENTS IN ORDER TO
CLARIFY THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
TO SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER PROGRAM. OF NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET ACT APPROPRIATE
AT THE FUNDING FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROGRAM
AND PROVIDED THE BOARD WITH
THIS EXEMPTION. SB TWO HUNDRED
HOWEVER FAILED TO INCLUDE
SECTION EXEMPTIONS. THIS BILL
WILL WIND THE EXEMPTIONS
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET ACT WITH
THE INTENT OF SB TWO HUNDRED.
FINALLY SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX WILL
PREVENT AND ADDRESS POTENTIAL
FRAUD IN THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
PROGRAM FUNDS. AS PROVISIONS
MERE EXISTING AUTHORITIES
CURRENTLY EXERCISED BY THE
WATER BOARD FOR OTHER FUNDS AND
ARE IMPORTANT TO HELP PREVENT
MISUSE OF PUBLIC FUNDS. PROTECT
COMMUNITIES AND HELP ACHIEVE
OUR SHARED CLEAN DRINKING WATER
GOALS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
I'M THANK YOU FOR THAT VERY
CLEAR TESTIMONY. BUT WE DO NOT
HAVE A PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION- WILL THEREFORE GO
TO THE ROOM IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE ROOM TO- WHO WILL SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION- WITHIN
GOING TO GO TO THE- REMOTE-
LOCATION OR ANYONE IN THE
REMOTE LOCATION ON THE NORTH
STEPS OF THE CAPITOL WHO WISHES
TO SPEAK. HEARING NONE WILL
THEN GO TO- THE PHONE LINES TO
GET THOSE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. FROM MODERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF SB. SEVEN SEVEN
SIX. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB SEVEN SEVEN
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME. ALLEN AT
T. OPERATORS GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND- GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER OFF
LINE IN PLACE YOU BACK IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME. TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR A. B. KEVIN
SEVEN SIX THANK YOU. AND I
MISTER CHAIR AT THIS TIME
NOBODY'S QUEUING UP. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT- SO SENATE SO ARE
THEIR COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
FISHER CAPELA CONCERNS AS A
RETIRED CONTRACTOR YOU MIGHT
WANNA MOVE UP YOUR MASS. HAVE
YOUR NOSE YEAH- IS IT A INTENT
OF THE LEGISLATION TO X. EXEMPT
THE STATE WATER BOARDS FROM
VARIOUS COMPETITIVE BIDDING AND
IF SO WHY WOULD BE IN A
CONTRACTOR I WANT TO BE
PERCEIVED AS ITS OPEN BIDDING
FOR EVERYONE OF SMALL COMPANIES
MINORITY COMPANIES AND LESS
COMPANIES TO DO WITHOUT BEING
AWARDED TO. HELLO
NONCOMPETITIVE BIDS. YEAH THANK
YOU- ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH THIS
DOESN'T. SPEAK TO THAT- THIS IS
BASICALLY AGAIN MAKING
CLARIFYING STATUTORY CHANGES
THAT WILL ENHANCE- SB TWO
HUNDRED WHICH IS A SAFE
DRINKING WATER ACT ENSURING
THAT THERE'S NO FRAUD AND
ENSURING THAT THERE'S MORE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
ACCESSIBLE DRINKING WATER TO
FOLKS. YOU HAVE THAT THE TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS WAS STRICTLY
FOR EMERGENCIES SUCH AS BUYING
WATER AND FOR THAT. THEY DON'T
HAVE TO DO CONTRACT THEY DON'T
HAVE TO HAVE GETTING. CORRECT
CORRECT OKAY SHOULD. YEP ALL
RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT SENATOR
PLEASE CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH YES-
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT BILL
IT'LL GIVE THE WATER BOARD THE
ABILITY TO USE THEM CIVIL
PENALTIES TO RECOUP A MISUSE
FUNDS- IT APPLIES NOW TO THE
SMALL WATER SYSTEMS FIVE TO
FOURTEEN CONNECTIONS AND UP TO
TWENTY FIVE PEOPLE. AND AGAIN
IT OFFER UP AUTHORIZES THE TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO ASSIST THE
SMALL WATER SYSTEMS IN
EMERGENCIES- I RECOMMENDED AYE
VOTE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS S. B.
SEVEN SEVEN SIX GONZALEZ. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
CORK BY CORK I SMITH. SMITH NO
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA HI OUR QUE
HAN OUR QUE HAN HI DALLI DALLI
NO CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA
GARCIA I HOLDEN. SHE MURATSUCHI
I. SO WE DO HAVE THE VOTES FOR
THAT TO PASS OKAY
CONGRATULATIONS SENATOR.
SENATOR HERTZBERG. EXCELLENT.
SO BILL IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED- NEXT WE HAVE S. B.
TWO SEVEN THREE WHICH IS
SENATOR HERTZBERG'S BAIL THAT
WOULD GRANT YOU MUNICIPAL WASTE
WATER AGENCIES THE EXPLICIT
AUTHORITY TO CAPTURE AND TREAT
STORM WATER AND DRY WEATHER
RUNOFF. PLEASE PROCEED SENATOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR WE ON
HERE YOU KNOW ME YEAH. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WHY DO I STAND BEFORE
YOU TODAY WITH THE BILL. WHAT'S
THE PROBLEM THAT WE'RE SEEKING
TO SOLVE OR IS THERE A PROBLEM
THERE'S JUST NO ONE OF THESE
CRAZY BILLS THAT OFTEN WE
SCRATCH OUR HEADS AND SAY. WHY
THE HECK DO REDUCES MEASURE.
WELL UNFORTUNATELY- THE IN THE
AREA WATER LAW. THERE'S A
MASSIVE REGULATIONS AND
DISTINCTIONS THAT EXIST.
THROUGH THE STATE LOCAL
AGENCIES STORM WATER AGENCIES.
INTO THE HISTORY OF ALL OF
THESE VARIOUS LAWS THERE'S BEEN
SOME CHALLENGES THAT ARE
PARTICULARLY INFORMED BY THE
DROUGHT THAT WE'RE FACING. TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN TO TWO
THOUSAND TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN LARGE
INFORMED FIFTY YEARS. THIS IS
AN EXTRAORDINARY STATEMENT SO
WE AS A GOVERNMENT NEED TO BE
AS CREATIVE AS WE POSSIBLY CAN
TO FIGURE IT OUT TO FIX IT AND
TO BREAK DOWN THOSE ROADBLOCKS
ONE OF THOSE ROADBLOCKS IS
ARTIFICIAL RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
MUNICIPAL WATER AGENCIES AND
STORM WATER AGENCIES STORMWATER
AS WAS INDICATED IN THE AND THE
AND THE IN THE SUPPORT LETTER
FROM THE OCEAN STOP- BECAUSE
KEEPERS. IS A VALUABLE RESOURCE
WE SHOULD BE DOING EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO CAPTURE THAT
RESOURCE I INTRODUCED A BILL
THAT WAS QUITE CONTROVERSIAL
SOME YEARS AGO TWO THIRTY ONE
INVOLVING THE DISTINCTION
BETWEEN WATER AND STORMWATER
WHAT THIS DOES IS IT ALLOWS
BECAUSE THE LAW THERE'S A
EXCUSE NO DISRESPECT SIR BUT
THERE'S A QUIRK IN THE LAW.
THAT REQUIRES A CHANGE BECAUSE
OF THIS DISTINCTION SO TO MAKE
IT EASY THERE'S ONLY FOUR
DISTRICTS TO DO THIS NOW TO
ALLOW VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS TO
BE ENTERED INTO. WHAT IS THESE
VARIOUS WATER DISTRICTS ARE
FACED WITH EXTRAORDINARY
CHALLENGES AND WE'RE TRYING TO
MAKE IT EASIER FOR THEM AS WE
FACE CLIMATE CHANGE FACE THESE
DROUGHTS AND TRY TO UPDATE AND
CORRECT THE LAW ALL CONSISTENT
OF COURSE WITH THE KNOX CORTESE
HERTZBERG LEFT CO ACTIVE TWO
THOUSAND. SO WHICH IS MENTIONED
IN THE MEASURE SO WITH THAT I
HAPPEN TO ANSWER THE QUESTIONS
AND. ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE. EXCELLENT THANK
YOU FOR TALKING TO US AND I DO
MEAN THAT BECAUSE YOU WERE
TALKING TO US NOT JUST READ
THAT'S THAT'S NICE- SO NOW WE
HAVE TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT-
TESTIFYING ON THE PHONE LINES
FIRST. JESSICA GALLAGHER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SANITATION
AGENCIES IS ON THE PHONE LINE.
THESE ARE PRETTY PROCEED WITH
YOUR TESTIMONY. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THIS IS
JESSICA GALLAGHER WITH
CALIFORNIA FIFTY CENTS IN
ADDITION AGENCIES HERE TODAY
UNVEILED THE PORT AT THAT
COSPONSORED THE BILL WITH WATER
AGENCIES ARE WELL SUITED TO
HELP STORM WATER PERMIT YOU TO
COMPLY WITH THEIR MANAGEMENT
OBLIGATIONS WHEN CIRCUMSTANCES
ALLOW MIDDLE COOPERATIVE
PROJECT OF THE PROJECT CAN BE
MULTI BENEFICIAL. THEY CAN
ACHIEVE- POLLUTION REDUCTION AS
WELL AS THE BENEFICIAL REUSE
THEM AND OFTEN OVERLOOKED AN
UNTAPPED SOURCE OF WATER. SB
TWO SEVENTY THREE BUILDS UP
PRIOR LEGISLATION THAT GRANTED
SPECIAL AUTHORITY TO SEVERAL
INDIVIDUAL WASTEWATER AGENCY TO
ENTER INTO VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS
TO DIVERT AND TREAT DRY WEATHER
RUNOFF AND STORMWATER IN THEIR
SERVICE AREAS THE PROJECT HAS
BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL IN THIS
BILL JUST EXTENDS THAT
AUTHORITY TO ALWAYS WATER
PROVIDERS IN CALIFORNIA. WE
BELIEVE THIS BILL REMOVES THE
BARRIERS FOR AGENCIES
CONSIDERING REGIONAL ONE WATER
APPROACHES TO WATER MANAGEMENT
WHILE PROVIDING ADEQUATE
PROTECTION TO ALL INVOLVED
STAKEHOLDERS I FINALLY JUST
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT PROVIDING THE
MAJORITY IS ALSO A PRIORITY
OUTLINED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
WATER RESILIENCE PORTFOLIO WITH
THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY.
QUESTIONS IN WINCHESTER DRIVE
OUT- THANK YOU. I NEVER WILL
FROM. EIGHT IN. ON BEHALF THE-
COAST KEEPER ALLIANCE ON THE
PHONE LINE- PLEASE PROCEED WITH
YOUR TESTIMONY. MORNING CHECK
WORK AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MANDATING TREATMENT
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA COAST PEOPLE
ALLIANCE. A CO SPONSOR OF
SENATE BILL TWO SEVEN THREE
ALONGSIDE THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION SANITATION AGENCIES.
CALIFORNIA'S WATER CHALLENGES
ARE MOUNTING MORE INTENSE
DROUGHTS INCREASED FLOODING AND
INCREASING CREDIT POLLUTION IN
TWENTY TWELVE TO TWENTY SIXTEEN
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCED ITS MOST
SEVERE DROUGHT ON RECORD.
INTERFACING YET ANOTHER
HISTORIC DROUGHT THIS YEAR.
UNFORTUNATELY MUCH OF OUR STATE
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE IS
OUTDATED AND TRADITIONAL
THINKING ON WATER MANAGEMENT.
HAS NOT KEPT PACE WITH EMERGING
CHALLENGES AND OPPORTUNITIES
SUCH AS STORMWATER CAPTURE AND
WATER RE USE. SB TWO SEVENTY
THREE WILL AUTHORIZE MUNICIPAL
WASTE WATER AGENCIES. TO ENTER
INTO VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS.
ROOFS STORMWATER MANAGEMENT AND
TREAT STORMWATER OF THE LOCAL
WATER RESOURCE IN TURN REDUCING
LIABILITY FOR MUNICIPALITIES.
NO STORM WATER POLLUTION IS
REDUCED. STORMWATER CAPTURE IN
TREATMENT IN AUGMENTED INCREASE
THE RESILIENCE OF CALIFORNIA'S
STATE AND LOCAL WATER SUPPLIES.
THIS IS A RESOURCE AND
OPPORTUNITY THAT SHOULD NOT BE
MISSED BY THOSE MUNICIPALITIES
AND SANITATION AGENCIES WHO
VOLUNTARILY CHOOSE TO UPGRADE
AND CONSOLIDATED SYSTEMS. WE
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE YOUR MOVE
EXISTING BARRIERS TO THESE
INNOVATIVE WATER PROJECTS. BY
AUTHORIZING MUNICIPAL WASTE
WATER AGENCIES. YOUR DIVERT
CAPTURE AND TREAT THE
STORMWATER THAT RUNS OFF OUR
STREETS. WATER QUALITY AND
COURAGE LOCAL WATER SECOND
THANK YOU. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- NOW IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY ON THIS. BILL. ANYONE
ON THE NORTH STEPS WHO WISHES
TO TESTIFY. PHONE MODERATOR
WOULD YOU- SEE IF THE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ON THE LINE IT
WISHES TO TESTIFY- THEY WILL
GIVE THEIR NAME THEIR POSITION
AND ANY AFFILIATION. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN- LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE PHONE LINES IF
YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
FOR S. B. TWO SEVENTY THREE
TAKE IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR. YES
YES SUPPORT IN OKAY CONDITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION ON S. B. TWO SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZEROS ON EIGHTEEN T. AFTER
TO GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER WILL
BEGIN TODAY WITH WIND FOURTEEN.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS BASS- ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE INLAND EMPIRE
UTILITIES AGENCY IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE TWENTY
SIX YOU ARE OPEN. THE MORNING
JAMIE MINOR ON BEHALF OF
EASTERN MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT IN SANTA MARGARITA
WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT
THANKS MUCH. NEXT IS ONE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE BALKANS OFFICE ON
BEHALF OF THIS- ORANGE COUNTY
WATER DISTRICT AND THE CITY OF
THOUSAND OAKS AND ROSE BILL. IN
SUPPORT. LINE SEVENTEEN YOUR
OPEN. GOOD MORNING CLINTON
LEVEQUE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH COALITION
ADVOCACY IN SUPPORT. LINE
TWENTY THREE YOUR UP PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU AMPLE INTERNAL
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. LINE TWENTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD AND FOR ANYBODY ELSE
GOING AT ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
TO QUEUE UP ONE FILED BY ZERO.
TWENTY TWO YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN VIRTUALLY ALL
THE DEVASTATION CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. AND AS A FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO TO QUEUE UP FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION ON BILL S. B. TWO
SEVEN THREE. AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWENTY ONE. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT BECAUSE PAMELA
MILLER. WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL AGENCY
FORMATION COMMISSION IN SUPPORT
I WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR
CAN'T STAFF AND THE SPONSORS
FOR THE REASON AND THEN. THANK
YOU. M. MISTER CHAIR WE'VE
EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OPERATOR- SO. THAT
WAS QUITE A BIT OF TESTIMONY
YOU HAVE BOTH AQUA AND- AND THE
LAUGHTER- AGENCIES IN YOUR CAMP
THAT'S- THAT'S A GOOD BILL. ALL
RIGHT- QUESTIONS FROM FOLKS- MR
MATHIS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
CENTER I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'VE
DONE HERE AND I THINK WE ALL
DO- IT AS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
BEFORE LIKE TO BE A CO AUTHOR
ON THIS COURSE YOU HAVE YOU
HAVE YOU WE GET THAT- THE-
CHAIRMAN SAID BRING IN THIS
COALITION TOGETHER. WE'VE
WORKED IN AND DISCUSS THIS TYPE
OF LEGISLATION SINCE I WAS A
FRESHMAN IN THE FIRST MATCH SO.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE IT HIT THIS
POINT AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET
IT. GET THE GOVERNOR TO
ACTUALLY SIGN. WE WILL SEE. ALL
RIGHT- MISSPELLED K. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I JUST WANT TO
THANK MR MINCBERG AS WELL FOR
BRINGING THIS I THINK WE'RE NOT
DOING ENOUGH OF THIS VERY FRANK
WITH YOU I THINK THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP BUT JUST A STEP
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
MORE LEGISLATION THAT
CREATIVELY SOLVES WHAT IS AN
GIANT PROBLEM THAT WILL ONLY
GET WORSE IN THE COMING YEARS
AS WE FACE CLIMATE CHANGE SO I
WOULD TO LIKE TRYING TO CO
AUTHOR PHIL HADLEY. I'M HANDS
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION. THANK
YOU. YEAH OKAY MANY. ANALYSTS
WITH MEDICARE AND THEN- NICE
WALKING OVER HERE WAS VERY MUCH
TRYING TO GET CLOSE TO THE MIKE
BUT MIKE MASCOT. PRECIADO BUT I
GOT A PHONE CALL IT MIGHT BE
THIS BILL SB SIX HUNDRED MIGHT
BE IN CONFLICT WITH PROP. TO
EIGHTEEN DO YOU FEEL OF SOME
CONFLICT WITH TWO EIGHT TWO ONE
SIX PRESS WITH ALL THE SUPPORT
THAT'S THE DEBATE WE HAD SOME
YEARS AGO INVOLVING S. B. TWO
THIRTY ONE WHICH DEBT DEFINE
STORM WATER NO I DON'T THINK
SO. I KNOW THAT THERE'S AN
ARGUMENT IN THAT IN THAT
RESPECT AND THERE WAS A COURT
CASE IN SALINAS IN NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT WITH RESPECT TO
THAT ISSUE. AND IT'S GOING TO
BE LITIGATED AGAIN AND I'M SURE
THAT WE WITH A WILL BUT- BUT
THE IDEA IS- THIS ALLOWS FOR
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENT SO IT'S
SUSPECTED WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IS. THE WATER LAWYERS ON
LIKE A STATUTORY MANDATE THAT
WE DID ON TWO THIRTY ONE- I
CAN'T WROTE YOUR THAT WAS. BUT
IS QUITE DIFFERENT BECAUSE THE
LAWYERS WILL DRAFT THIS IN A
WAY TO AVOID LITIGATION RISK
IT'S A DIFFERENT THANK. BECAUSE
THE QUESTION AS WELL THIS WATER
STORMWATER AND WHAT DOES THAT
LOOK LIKE IN THE QUESTION IS
CAN YOU ADD A FEATURE TO IT
WELL THOSE ARE GOING TO BE
QUESTIONS THAT WILL BE WILL BE-
NETTED OUT WITH RESPECT TO THE
LAWYERS WHEN THEY- DRAFT THESE
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS WITH THE
FEE STRUCTURE IS HOW THOSE
CHARGES ARE MADE. THOSE ARE THE
THINGS THAT CREATE THE
CHALLENGES IN PROP TO EIGHTEEN
WHICH THE HOWARD JARVIS FOLKS
WERE CONCERNED ABOUT WHEN THEY
HAD LITIGATION SALINAS VERSUS
HOWARD JARVIS BACK IN NINETY
EIGHT. MAYBE WAS EIGHTY EIGHT
EIGHT HUNDRED NUMBERS ANYMORE
BUT THE POINT IS THAT I DON'T
THINK IT'LL BE A PROBLEM
PERFECT THANK YOU LOOK FORWARD
TO SUPPORT IT ABSOLUTELY THANK
YOU. EXCELLENT AND THEN- MR
MURATSUCHI THANK YOU SIR I I'M
HEARING ALL THESE. GREAT THINGS
ABOUT YOUR. BILL BUT I JUST
WANT TO UNDERSTAND UP- MAKE
SURE AND- IT IS A FROM THE
PRESS OF THE STORM WATER
TREATMENT COSTS I KNOW THAT MY
CITIES IN THE SOUTH BAY OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY ARE YOU KNOW
EVER SINCE I ARRIVED HERE
THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT HOW. THE THE REQUIREMENTS
THE CLEAN- CLEAN AND TREAT THE
STORMWATER RUNOFF IS SO
OVERWHELMING THAT- THAT THEY
THEY JUST CAN'T AFFORD IT HOW
IS THIS BILL GOING TO- HELLO
THIS IS DAVID THE PROBLEM L. A.
COUNTY PARTICULARLY COMMITTEES
REPRESENT. WAS THESE NPDES
PERMITS- THAT ARE REQUIRED IN
THE COSTA COUNTY PASSED TONIGHT
I DIDN'T REALLY SUPPORTED
THOUGHT HOW THEY DONE IT WAS
WRONG THIS HUGE OBLIGATION
THINKING COULD BE AS MUCH AS
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS IMPOSE
PARTICULAR IN SMALLER CITIES
YOUR CITIES GLENDORA SOME OF
THE CITY'S REALLY HAD ITS REAL
CHALLENGE WITH THAT SOME YEARS
AGO WHEN THAT PASS AND I GET.
OFF ON BECAUSE THEY WERE
WORRIED ABOUT THESE PROPERTY
TAX ASSESSMENTS MY CONCERN
WHICH IS QUITE DIFFERENT YEAR
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS A
VERY I THINK AS- THE SEVEN
ABOUT QUE HAN SAID IS KIND OF
AN ELEGANT SOLUTION BECAUSE-
WHAT'S HAPPENING IS. THAT THE
LAW THAT WAS PASSED THE IT IS
THE BOND ISSUES PASSED IN LOS
ANGELES TALK ABOUT REQUIRING
CLEANUP CAPPED IT TAKE RUN OFF
CLEAN. IT UP AND TOWARD THE
OCEAN RIGHT. YEAH THIS ANY OF
THIS- LOOKING YOU GOTTA HOLD OF
YOU HEAD WHY NOT. THAT WATER.
THAT WERE CAUSING PROBLEMS FOR
THE FARMERS IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WE'RE CAUSING FOR
PROBLEMS WITH WITH WITH LAKE
MADE AT THE RIVER AND ALL THE
STUFF IS GONE SALTON CITY. WERE
CAUSING PROBLEMS IN THE NORTH.
WE SHOULD BE RESPONSIBLE TO
CAPTURE EVERY DROP OF WATER
PARTICULARLY THAT CHALLENGE
THAT WE'RE FACING IN THE
DROUGHT. SO WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IN THIS MEASURE AS
OPPOSED TO WHAT HAPPENED. UNDER
THE BOND ISSUE THE THAT YOU'RE
CITIES WERE SO UPSET ABOUT. IS
THAT THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
CAPTURE AND MAKE MONEY RIGHT TO
RECYCLE THAT WATER TO RECHARGE
THE GROUNDWATER WHICH IS SO
IMPORTANT. METROPOLITAN WATER
IS THE ONLY COUNTY IS
INCREDIBLE MAP WHICH ON THE
DOOR OF MY OFFICE MY DISTRICT
WHICH SHOWS ALL THE PLACES
THROUGHOUT BOTH ORANGE COUNTY
L. A. COUNTY. WELL WE CAN
RECHARGE THE GROUNDWATER. TO
ELIMINATE THESE LARGER PROBLEMS
WE SHOULD RESTRUCTURE WATER
POLICY IN CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY. AT A TIME WHEN
WE'RE FACING SUCH AN EXTRA
NEGATIVELY WHAT FACING THE DROP
WE SHOULD BE DOING THIS. SO
THIS DID THIS IS A THIS IS A
STORY CORK IN THE LAW WHERE.
WE'VE GOT THESE STUPID SILOS
ALL OVER THE PLACE BECAUSE OF
HISTORICAL REASONS. AND WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS TO BE
CREATIVE COMING UP WITH WAYS.
WHERE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS CAN
WORK TOGETHER SAY WATER AND
ALSO POSSIBLY TAKE THAT WATER.
THAT RIGHT NOW YOUR CITY HAS TO
PAY TO PUT THE OCEAN MAYBE THEY
COULD TURN INTO AN ASSET. THEY
DON'T HAVE TO BUY WATER AT
ELEVEN DOLLARS AN ACRE FOOT.
THAT'S THE REASON SO IT'S A
REALLY IT'S TO ME IT'S
COMPLIMENTARY IT SHOULD BE
SUPPORTIVE OF. BUT YOUR POINT
IS BRILLIANTLY TAKEN AND I
AGREE WITH YOU AND I DIDN'T
SUPPORT THAT WATER BOND THE
TIME. PRECISELY FOR THAT REASON
IS WE SHOULDN'T JUST SAY WE'RE
GONNA CLEAN UP THE WATER WE
SHOULD CLEAN IT UP AND CAPTURED
BECAUSE IT'S CLEAN UP TO
FEDERAL STANDARDS. FROM WHICH
WE CAN THEN HAVE. PIPES BUILT A
RECHARGE GROUNDWATER WHICH
WOULD BE TELE POLICY WHICH IS
ULTIMATELY WHAT I WANT TO GO IN
THE WATER SPACE. SO STATE
ABILITY. LESS RELIANCE LESS
POLITICAL ARCHITECTURE. MORE
HARMONY AMONG FOLKS IN THE
WATER WORLD SILICIFIED BY
ENCOURAGING THAT THE CAPTURE.
AND THE TREATMENT FOR. PURPOSES
LIKE RECHARGING THE- AQUIFER
OR- ARE USING IT FOR. FOR
IRRIGATION OR OTHER PURPOSES.
THAT COULD POTENTIALLY REDUCE
THE COSTS TO. MY CITIES IN
TERMS OF COURSE THEY THAT THE
TREATMENT- SURE IT'S A REVENUE
STREAM. OR TAKE A MESSAGE
YOU'RE IN YOU'RE YOU'RE BEING
MANDATED TO PUT IN THE OCEAN.
YOU KNOW. I MEAN IT'S TERMINAL
BOX ROCKS I JUST IT JUST
CRAZIER THAN TO ME. BUT THE
PEOPLE THAT WERE BEHIND IT WAS
SO CONCERNED ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PIECE THEY
WEREN'T THINKING ABOUT THE
WATER SUPPLY PIECE AND THE
OTHER PIECE OF SUSTAINABILITY.
AND ALSO THE POLITICS OF WATER
FOR CALIFORNIA WHICH AS WE ALL
KNOW. WHISKEY'S FOR DRINKING A
WATER FIGHT OVER. AND IT HAS
ALWAYS BEEN A PROBLEM. AND WE
NEED TO BE SMART ABOUT IT IN
PARTICULAR IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE'RE BOTH FROM. WE
GOTTA BE DOUBLY SMART. ABOUT
IT. OKAY THANK YOU. I HAVE
NEVER HAD AN AUTHOR. WHO KNEW
MORE ABOUT THIS BILL. GEN YOU
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SO AGAIN
THESE ARE VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS
UP OF ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. ALL
RIGHT THEN- YOU MAY CLOSE WELL
MISTER CHAIRMAN IS NO MAGIC I
STARTED WORKING ON THIS SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE AND I
PROBABLY FORGOT A LOT OF IT
I'VE BEEN WHAT MY DISSERTATION
A WATER BACK THEN AND I'M
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE WITH THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE BOND ISSUES
WITH ALL KINDS OF STUFF. YOU
KNOW EVEN THOUGH I'M FROM AN
URBAN AREA I'VE ALWAYS SEEN IT
TO BE IMPORT SO CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AND SO THERE'S NO
MAGIC IN IT IT'S JUST. YOU KNOW
A LOT OF ELBOW GREASE OVER A
LOT OF YEARS. WELL IF YOU
HAPPEN TO IT AND- CAN I JUST
READ AYE VOTE. EXCELLENT WORK-
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS S. B. TWO SEVENTY
THREE HERTZBERG. THE MOTION IS
DO YOU PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
QUIRK I WORK AYE SMITH SMITH I
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA I OUR QUE
HAN BARRICADE HANNAH HI DALLI
DALLI II CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I MATHIS MATHIS I WOULD
HAVE TO G. MODES WHICH ARE SO
THAT'S UNANIMOUS. THANK YOU
EVERYONE THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PRESENTING I
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH IT'S AN
HONOR TO BE YEAH COMMITTEE
THANK YOU WELL EVERYONE CAN BE
QUITE HAPPY WE FINISHED OUR-
HEARING. AND- DO WE HAVE A WE
HAVE A MR HOLDEN TO- ADD ON TO-
THE BILL THAT'S PASSED ALREADY.
YES SO THIS IS- SB SEVEN SEVEN
SIX GONZALEZ THE VOTE COUNT IS
SITS AT FIVE THREE. HOLDEN
HOLDEN I. THAT SIX THREE OKAY I
DON'T THINK I EVER GOT ANYTHING
ELSE SO THANK YOU EVERYONE.
HEARINGS OVER.